Taylor Swift took the crown from Queen
Bee as her Blockbuster the eras tour
earned her $35 million more than double
what Beyonce took home for her
record-breaking Renaissance
tour here are the top earning summer
concerts of
20123 number seven Elton
[Music]
John having toured since the 1970s the
Rocket Man had his final splash down in
July since 2018 when farewell Yellow
Brick Road began the 76-year-old JN has
played 330 shows and worn some 16 Gucci
outfits John's last glenberry appearance
in June Drew an A-list crowd including
Paul McCartney Kate Hudson Debbie Harry
Ana Taylor joy and Lewis
Hamilton number six Harry
[Music]
Styles before music fans were
coordinated ating themed outfits for the
eras and Renaissance tours they were
buying groovy costumes and feather boas
for Harry Styles love on tour after
kicking off in 2021 when it quickly
became the most attended tour of the
Year Styles Love Fest finally wrapped up
in July he spent most of 2023 playing to
International audiences first in Oceania
then Asia before wrapping up in Europe
it concluded with a total gross of $617
million having sold more than 5 million
tickets across 169
shows number five
[Music]
pink only pink could perform two tours
at once while hanging upside down in
October she took a break from her summer
carnival tour to start her 20-day trust
fall tour shows for a musician who
famously flies through the air and
performs acrobatics during her shows
pink also shattered a glass ceiling this
year in August she became the first
woman to headline a Stadium concert in
Wisconsin number four
Coldplay for its Music of the Spheres
World Tour econscious Coldplay kept the
production as sustainable as possible
the stage was built from reusable
materials the confetti was biodegradable
and the LED wristbands given to fans
were
compostable band members Chris Martin
Johnny Buckland guy barryman and Will
Champion visited 10 countries this
summer in South America and Europe after
a stint in North America the band will
head to Asia and returned to Europe in
2024 number three Ed
[Music]
Sheeran fittingly the 2023 leg of Ed
Sheeran's mathematics tour did Big
Numbers his paired down production style
and average ticket price of roughly $100
allowed the 32-year-old Sheeran to net a
a greater portion of ticket sales
compared to his Superstar competitors
Sheeran started the year in New Zealand
before ending the tour in the US along
the way he broke a record at Levi
Stadium in Santa Clara California
performing in front of more than 77,000
fans number two
Beyonce by the time the Renaissance tour
wrapped up in early October after stops
in 12 countries it grossed 500 $79
million making it one of the highest
grossing tours in history for Beyonce's
42nd birthday show in Los Angeles in
September she asked concert goers to
wear silver and those in attendance
including Megan Markle Chris Rock Jeff
Bezos and Tyler Perry did as Queen be
commanded number one Taylor
Swift Taylor Swift may be doing a mini
tour of luxury boxes at Kansas City
Chiefs games right now but for most of
the year she was selling out
stadiums an average ticket price of
$253 and ticket Master's crash during
the sale didn't deter concert goers
she's played to More Than 3 million
adoring fans so far some Die Hard
swifties also waited hours in line for
the chance to purchase coveted $75
hoodies though everyone knows there are
plenty of free friendship bracelets to
be traded in the
stands
[Music]